kehrtwende für den klimaschutz us
präsident biden will den ausstoß von
treibhausgasen bis 2030 halbieren impfen
bald für alle bundesgesundheitsminister
sparen rechnet im juni mit der aufhebung
der bisherigen reihenfolge wohl ab
samstag kommen nächtliche
ausgangsbedingungen für große teile
deutschlands
denn auch der bundesrat stimmt dem neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz zu
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers 7 sie uns 20 minuten
für diesen nachrichten donnerstag gute
nacht hinein katja stresow ist bei uns
und steuert den sport bei guten amt wir
beginnen mit einem radikalen kurswechsel
der usa beim klimaschutz
wir müssen handeln wir haben keine
andere wahl sagt der us präsident heute
und setzt seinem land ziele die fast
doppelt so hoch liegen wie der im
pariser klimaabkommen angestrebte wert
er will damit zeigen mit den usa ist bei
dem thema wieder zu rechnen und er will
weltweit druck machen
joe biden kündigt an die treibhausgase
bis 2030 um mindestens 50 prozent zu
reduzieren
ein deutliches zeichen zu beginn eines
virtuellen klimagipfels mit rund 40
vertretern aus aller welt dabei auch
russlands präsident die deutsche
kanzlerin und der chinesische staatschef
wichtig denn china ist der weltweit
größte co2 verursacher gefolgt von den
usa elmar theveßen
das signal das jetzt aus dem weißen haus
kommt lässt alle aufhorchen weil es eng
wird fürs klima verpflichtet
us-präsident beiden sein land gleich zu
beginn auf neue klimaziele
die usa machen sich auf die
treibhausgase zu halbieren bis zum ende
dieses jahrzehnts
er setzt den ton für alle klimaschutz
als konjunkturprogramm wenn die menschen
über klima reden denke ich immer gleich
an jobs
beides riesiges infrastrukturprogramm
soll millionen von arbeitsplätzen
schaffen mit investitionen von über zwei
billionen dollar würden nicht nur die
stromnetze für wind- und solarenergie
wie hier in texas ausgebaut sondern neue
technologien vorangetrieben
zb anlagen die kohlenstoffe aus der luft
filtern
auch china will nun früher als bisher
geplant seine emissionen in den griff
bekommen klimaneutralität erreichen und
andere länder technologisch unterstützen
entwickelte länder müssen ihre klima
aktivitäten beschleunigen und
entwicklungsländer und konkret beim
übergang zu einer grünen wirtschaft mit
niedrigem co2 ausstoß helfen die
illegale abholzung der regenwälder will
der brasilianische präsident möglichst
schnell beenden und folgt dem
amerikanischen vorbild klimaneutralität
bis 20.30 eine eigene arbeitsgruppe soll
klären wie all die versprechen
finanziert werden können
auch russland will dabei mitmachen trotz
aller sonstigen differenzen
wir stehen vor einer globalen
herkulesaufgabe es geht ja um nicht mehr
und nicht weniger als die transformation
unserer ganzen lebens und
wirtschaftsweise zwei tage will der
gipfel besonders über technische
fortschritte beraten und über eine
massive unterstützung für jene länder
die am meisten unter dem klimawandel
leiden vorgang dass es hier bei uns aus
unserer zdf.umwelt redaktion guten
us-vorgaben ist das heute tatsächlich
einen wendepunkt also ein tag an dem wir
uns alle mal zurück erinnern werden ich
würde sagen ja das ist es national für
die usa auf jeden fall das ist ja die
abkehr von der nicht klimapolitik des ex
präsidenten
trump und joe biden hat völlig klar
gemacht er peilt die neuen nagte an die
grünen märkte wenn man so will da ist
viel viel geld zu verdienen und das
mögen die amerikaner jobs money und wenn
dabei noch klimaschutz rauskommen
wunderbar da ist das ein wendepunkt
international auch man kann jetzt nicht
mehr sagen ob die amis machen ja nix die
andere kammer machen kein klimaschutz
nein ist vorbei und jetzt müssen die
chinesen auch an und da gibt es ja auch
schon erste arbeitsgruppen da tut sich
was also ich glaube dass es in beiden
auf beiden ebenen wendepunkt die usa
sehen sich wieder als motor locken mit
sehr sehr viel geld was heißt das für
uns in deutschland
europa wir haben wir müssen einfach
schneller werden wir müssen die
klimaschutztechnologien die es bei uns
gibt jetzt in die weltmärkte bringen und
dazu ist viel viel mehr
forschungsleistung notwendig das muss
durch finanziert werden da geht es zum
beispiel um neue speichertechnologien
für ökostrom das kann man mit wärme
machen mit salzlösungen da geht es um
wasserstoff technologie
da brauchen wir nicht unbedingt ökostrom
für das geht doch direkt mit licht daran
wird geforscht das sind die super
technologien da entstehen dann auch bei
uns jobs wenn wir das nicht machen wenn
wir eines tages nach amerika gucken und
sagen schade wir waren doch mal
vorreiter
volker angriffs ist auch gleich noch bei
zdf heute live zum klimagipfel gemeinsam
mit der bundesumweltministerin um 19.30
in der zdf- heute- app auf youtube und
facebook zum mitdiskutieren volker
vielen tagen gern und jetzt unser
nächstes thema die korona pandemie und
insbesondere das impfen
gucken wir erst auf die aktuelle lage
sowie sie sich offiziell darstellt dem
robert koch institut wurden binnen 24
stunden 29 1518 neuinfektionen gemeldet
das sind 92 mehr als donnerstag vor
einer woche 2 159 todesfälle kamen hinzu
die sieben tage incidents liegt bei
161,1 der bundesgesundheitsminister
hofft dass die festgelegte im freien
folge im juni ersatzlos entfallen kann
alle die wollen könnten sich ab dann
registrieren lassen
bereits jetzt sind regional impfungen
für die sogenannte priorisierung gruppe
3 freigegeben also etwa für über
60-jährige für vor erkrankte polizisten
und personal im supermarkt das gilt im
saarland in rheinland-pfalz und in
sachsen und für eine impfung mit
astrazeneca können sich ab sofort alle
melden in diesen bundesländern
mecklenburg-vorpommern berlin bayern und
ebenfalls sachsen
von dort berichtet steffen moritz es
ging stiller als thomas hengst gedacht
hatte dienstag hörte er die nachricht
dass ich in sachsen nun jeder mit
astrazeneca impfen lassen darf heute
hatte der 58 jährige schon seinen termin
und ist glücklich
aus der ganzen misere oder aus der
ganzen krise oder wie man es auch nennen
mag hausärztin antje bergmann in dresden
kann sich seit der freigabe von
astrazeneca nicht retten vor anfragen
als der startschuss kamen priorisierung
aufgehoben für astrazeneca dann im
gleichen moment quasi haben die telefon
geglüht und die e-mail-flut war enorm
groß
auch aus anderen bundesländern kamen die
anfragen denn wäre denn der praxis von
anti bergmann der vector impfstoff nicht
so gut angenommen wurde und etwa 4 und
der dosen übrig sind die nun geimpft
werden können war astrazeneca in bayern
wohl beliebter in der praxis von peter
reis berkowitsch in gefrees ist der
kühlschrank leer
hier wird freigegeben sofort stehen bei
uns die menschen schlange und wollen
geimpft werden
und ich habe mit der apotheke gerade im
gespräch versucht nach zu bestellen und
es ist keine aussicht das astra liefert
dann doch es soll mehr impfstoff kommen
viel mehr so viel dass der
gesundheitsminister in berlin heute
angekündigt hat dass es schon bald für
alle reichen könnte so dass wir im mai
die prio gruppe 3 werden impfen können
und dann im juni die priorisierung
werden aufheben können fällt die
priorisierung auch ein großes thema beim
nächsten impfgipfel am montag die
impfkampagne nimmt immer mehr fahrt auf
die einheitliche kroner notbremse für
ganz deutschland kommt seit heute ist
das neue infektionsschutzgesetz
beschlossene sache auch der bundesrat
hat es passieren lassen
obwohl etliche ministerpräsidenten ist
gleichzeitig massiv kritisierten kurz
danach unterschrieb der bundespräsident
und jetzt wird es ganz schnell gehen
gültig in städten und landkreisen sind
die neuen regeln laut
bundesinnenministerium ab samstag heike
slansky
kein einspruch der länderkammer
zähneknirschend hat der bundesrat
gestern erst vom bundestag beschlossene
notbremse passieren lassen allerdings
mit heftiger kritik die
kompetenzverlagerung an den bund eine
zäsur
der heutige tag ist für mich ein
tiefpunkt in der föderalen kultur der
bundesrepublik deutschland an diesen
stellen gefällt es mir einfach nicht
dass seitdem keine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mehr
stattgefunden hat mich jetzt darauf
angewiesen bin talkshows mehr an zu
gucken um zu sehen was eventuell von mir
erwartet wird
der versuch die pandemien und zentral
statt lokal zu bekämpfen sei
unbefriedigend doch es gab auch
selbstkritik
die halbwertszeit von beschlüssen aus
dem bund länder beratung war in der
vergangenheit gelegentlich erstaunlich
kurz und ich glaube es war auch nicht in
jedem fall gut für das ansehen des
föderalismus verfassungsmäßige bedenken
ob denn eine instanz als alleiniger
maßstab für eine notbremse gelten könne
teilen die länderchefs nicht nur die fdp
und die freien wähler wollen
verfassungsbeschwerde einreichen
wir kritisieren in erster linie holt er
auch mit unserer verfassungsbeschwerde
diesen automatismus der ausgangssperre
die ohne rücksicht auf sonstige eckdaten
einfach sorgt ab 100 darf man um 22 uhr
nicht mehr raus das gesetz tritt bereits
morgen in kraft notbremse und
ausgangssperren modellprojekte stehen
vor dem aus die dritte welle hat
deutschland fest im griff
und dann schauen wir mal was das gesetz
jetzt konkret für uns alle in
deutschland bedeutet es geht los bei
einer inzidenz von über 100 und das
betrifft aktuell 84 prozent aller
landkreise und städte
für sie heißt das ab samstag unter
anderem nächtliche ausgangsbedingungen
ab einer inzidenz von 150 dürfen in den
läden nur noch bestellte waren abgeholt
werden und ab in's events 165 müssen die
schulen wieder in den distanz unterricht
das betrifft nach den heutigen zahlen
immerhin knapp die hälfte aller kreise
julia schröter und ariane gödel
musikus im gymnasium am kaiserdom in
speyer
noch ist wechsel unterricht in der
klasse möglich bei incidents knapp unter
200 mit der bundes notbremse sind auch
hier alle wieder im distanz unterricht
das ist natürlich schade wenn man wieder
nach hause muss aber zum wohle von allen
und auch für die zukunft dass wir dann
vielleicht in einer cola freien zukunft
leben können finde ich das gut insgesamt
die zahlen hier gerade hier in speyer
steigen deutlich an also definitiv die
richtige entscheidung der fernunterricht
hat hier gut geklappt auch deshalb hätte
sich der schulleiter distanz unterricht
schon auf einem niedrigeren wert als 165
vorstellen können
wichtig für ihn kein ständiges hin und
her lieber vier wochen zu und dann
richtiger unterricht als bis zum
schuljahresende immer nur wechsel
unterricht für die bonner mode händlerin
karin neuer feind bedeutet die bundes
notbremse noch weniger umsatz
die inzidenz aktuell 183 damit können
kunden bei der einzelhändlerin nur vor
bestellte ware an der tür abholen doch
zu wenige nutzen dass die kunden müssen
stöbern müssen anprobieren die müssen
sich inspirieren lassen
beraten das geht nicht vor der türe die
ideale vorstellung für die
ladeninhaberin einkaufen mit negativen
schnelltest wie zuletzt
die kunden hatten sich jetzt daran
gewöhnt wir haben die tests gemacht
diesen reingekommen haben die namen
aufgeschrieben
wir haben auch wieder geschrieben den
sie gegangen sind das war toll die
bundes notbremse sie bringt einheitliche
regeln und ganz individuelle probleme
indien hat heute einen traurigen rekord
aufgestellt in 24 stunden wurden dort so
viele neuansteckungen gemeldet wie noch
nie zuvor weltweit in den letzten fünf
wochen hat sich die zahl der hat sich
deren zahl fast verzehnfacht und das
obwohl kaum getestet wird
schuld ist auch eine neue corona
variante das marode gesundheitssystem
kann längst nicht mehr alle versorgen
normen odenthal zu hause sitzen kranke
deren luft zum atmen knapp wird das
macht ihre angehörigen hier zu geben
dutzende männer fühlen dann das
sauerstoff lager des krankenhauses der
verstand setzt aus wenn es ums überleben
geht
diese plünderer sollten ihr hirn
einschalten ärzte krankenschwestern
pfleger arbeiten rund um die uhr gehen
über ihre grenzen und diese leute klauen
sauerstoff sie wissen doch gar nicht wie
man damit umgeht sauerstoff ist das was
fehlt diesen patienten und dem ganzen
land das virus das die lunge angreift
macht ganz indien zum notfall sie haben
irgendwo eine sauerstoffflasche
aufgetrieben ihren pkw zum krankenwagen
umgebaut das muss gehen bis im
krankenhaus endlich platzt wird
sie hätten schon die ganze nacht
gewartet sagt er und hofft dass sein
sohn vielleicht in einer stunde dran
kommen wird diese welle hat es ihnen
sich 315.000 neuinfektionen allein heute
ein desaströser weltrekord eine neue
virus mutation ist offenbar extrem
ansteckend doch es kommt mehr dazu eine
impfkampagne die stockt eine bevölkerung
die sich lange sorglos gab eine
regierung die auf viele zögerlich wirkt
wir müssen unser land vor einem
kompletten lockdown bewahren
die wirtschaftlichen gefahren sind groß
ein lockdown darf nur die letzte option
sein
wann kommt die zeit für diese letzte
option in den krematorien ist alles
schon zu spät die zahl der toten wächst
rasant
schreckliche bilder aus indien und so
fiel zunächst zum thema krone im
konflikt zwischen der ukraine und
russland sendet präsident wladimir putin
heute signale der entspannung
er sei bereit den ukrainischen
präsidenten volume ii sc lenski in
moskau zu empfangen sagte putin
sofort der see lenski ein treffen mit
putin in der umkämpften ost ukraine
vorgeschlagen
darüber hinaus kündigte russlands
verteidigungsminister an morgen mit dem
abzug der truppen zu beginnen die in den
letzten wochen entlang der grenze zur
ukraine stationiert worden waren
in russland sind bei protesten für den
inhaftierten kremlkritiker alexej
nawalny etwa 1700 menschen festgenommen
worden
allein in sankt petersburg waren das
rund 300 teilten menschenrechtler mit
zehntausende waren gestern im ganzen
land auf die straße gegangen und
forderten das navalny schnell
unabhängige ärztliche hilfe bekommt sein
gesundheitszustand hatte sich nach
angaben seines teams zuletzt massiv
verschlechtert navalny ist seit drei
wochen im hungerstreik zurück nach
deutschland und zum wohl größten
finanzskandal der deutschen
nachkriegsgeschichte der fall wirecard
im juni 2020 musste der einstige dax
konzern einräumen 1,9 milliarden euro
aus der bilanz fehlen
der skandal war weder den
wirtschaftsprüfern aufgefallen und auch
der fiel auch die finanzaufsicht bafin
hatte lange keinen alarm geschlagen
und diese behörde wiederum ist dem
finanzministerium unterstellt deshalb
musste heute finanzminister olaf scholz
als zeuge vor dem untersuchungsausschuss
des bundestages die frage dort trifft
ihn eine mitschuld
florian a als olaf scholz am vormittag
in den bundestag kommt steht seine
wichtigste antwort längst fest nein er
der finanzminister trage keine
verantwortung im fall wirecard wird
scholz im untersuchungsausschuss sagen
und wieder und wieder auf die kriminelle
energie an der spitze von wirecard
verweisen sowohl die opposition als auch
der eigene koalitionspartner wollen das
so nicht stehen lassen
die maßgebliche politische verantwortung
für diesen wirecard skandal trägt der
bundesfinanzminister
ich habe das gefühl der olaf scholz
kriegt den wasserhahn gar nicht mehr zu
so oft wie er seine hände in unschuld
gewaschen hat der zahlungsdienstleister
wirecard hatte jahrelang wohl bilanzen
gefälscht ergebnis ein schaden in
milliarden höhe
doch statt betrugs hinweisen nachzugehen
hatte sich die dem finanzministerium
unterstellte finanzaufsicht bafin immer
wieder schützend vor das unternehmen
gestellt
scholz kontert man habe nach der pleite
schnell reagiert um die finanzaufsicht
zu stärken
das haben wir gemacht mit einem gesetz
das jetzt im bundestag abschließend
beraten wird das haben wir gemacht mit
einer neuaufstellung der
aufsichtsbehörde bafin wirbel gibt es im
ausschuss um e-mails die scholz von
seiner privatadresse zu wirecard
geschrieben hatte und die dem ausschuss
nicht vorlagen
dass sie brisantes enthielten dafür gibt
es keine hinweise was der
untersuchungsausschuss war ja karte in
wenigen monaten an kontrollversagen
zutage gefördert hat
das war bisweilen atemberaubend dem
finanzminister olaf scholz konnte der
ausschuss keinen persönlichen fehler
nachweisen
und so ging es heute wohl eher um die
politische bewertung des
kanzlerkandidaten olaf scholz
der wahlkampf hat nun auch den wirecard
untersuchungsausschuss erreicht morgen
vernehmen sie hier die bundeskanzlerin
viel los heute an diesem donnerstag
jetzt gleich rüber zum sport und zur ihr
könnt mit fußball los die deutsche
fußball liga hat die korona regeln
verschärft in der ersten und zweiten
liga müssen alle vereine vor den letzten
drei spieltagen zunächst in eine
häusliche quarantäne und sich danach in
einem quarantäne trainingslager komplett
abschotten
nachdem mit hertha bsc erstmals ein
bundesligist in quarantäne geschickt
werden musste war mit verschärften
maßnahmen der dfl gerechnet worden
der zwei-stufen-plan zieht vom dritten
mann zunächst vor dass sich spieler und
betreuer außer auf dem trainingsgelände
und dem stadion nur noch im häuslichen
umfeld aufhalten dürfen vom 12 mai an
darf dann nur noch im hotel gewohnt
werden zustimmung aus den vereinen
lichtes sind notwendig angemessen
richtig wir wohl natürlich alle im sinne
des gemeinsamen interesses die
bundesliga auch sauber fertig spielen
wegen der anstehenden
europameisterschaft im juni sind allzu
viele spiel verschiebungen in dieser
saison nämlich gar nicht mehr drin
in basel in der schweiz finden momentan
die ton europameisterschaften statt
elisabeth seitz und kim bui stehen im
morgige mehrkampffinale und für ein
novum sorgt der teamkollegin sarah voss
die im kampf gegen sexualisierung
erstmals mit einem ganzkörperanzug
konnte am schwebebalken verpasst du die
deutsche mehrkampf-meisterin die
qualifikation zur medaillenentscheidung
nur knapp doch ihr erster auftritt im
langen bein anzug sorgte schon für
aufsehen genug das unbehagen dass sie
und andere turnerinnen früher im
gewohnten kurz geschnittenen anzug
begleitet hatte war zu störend geworden
ist wir dann auch irgendwann mal einfach
an gemerkt haben dass wir uns nicht
immer wohlfühle dabei dass wir das
gefühl haben merkt zu sein
oder dass etwas verrutschen könnte das
war uns dass öfteren auch sehr
unangenehm
elisabeth seitz am stufenbarren hat das
einzel und auch das mehrkampffinale in
basel ebenso erreicht wie boden turnerin
kim bui die beiden stuttgarterinnen
wollen die kommenden em wettkämpfe auch
im langen ton anzug bestreiten und damit
vorbild für die jungen turnerinnen seien
viel lang hat ja schauen wir noch kurz
aufs wetter sonne und wolken sind im
programm gleich bei austin tel
dann empfehle ich ihnen das heute
journal mit kollegin marietta slomka um
21 45 vom gesamten team der heute 19
danke für ihr interesse
gern bis morgen wenn sie mögen aber erst
in allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter beständig kommt
die kalte luft aus dem norden und setzt
sich etwa bis zur mitte deutschlands
durch im süden ist es etwas milder
diese mehr regionale wetterlage von nord
nach süd haben wir jetzt schon längere
zeit und hauptsächlich liegt das an hoch
sie sich über dem nordmeer oder über den
britischen inseln jedenfalls über dem
westlichen europa bilden und so die
kalte luft aus dem norden zu uns lenken
schauen wir in die nacht da gibt es
einige wolken im norden weiter richtung
ostsee klart es auf und auch im süden
oder dort wird es am kältesten mit
temperaturen bis minus 3 grad fünf grad
plus gibt es an der nordsee morgen
tagesverlauf von der ems bis über die
mitte nach zum erzgebirge kompakte
wolken örtlich davon viel sonnenschein
und auch im süden da gibt es kaum wolken
am himmel bei höchsten temperaturen von
19 grad im südwesten sehen hier häufig
werte um die 15 grad marke sonst ist es
deutlich kühler und darunter die
nächsten tage gehen im großen ganzen so
weiter viele wollten am samstag in der
mitte aber viel sonne im süden bei 10
bis 20 grad und auch ab sonntag sieht es
so ähnlich aus damit ein schöner abend